most people who've made millions started
with something that got them a hundred
grand and i will tell you personally
the first hundred thousand dollars that
i put in my bank account was by far the
most meaningful that of all the money
that i've made in my life
[Music]
what's going on everyone i've got a
special uh podcast episode for you today
um what i want to break down is a
conversation i was having with a
different friend about how 100
dollars is the hardest amount of money
to make um
and i was actually talking to him he's
uh he's starting his physical therapy
uh clinic practice right now um
and he's he's he's you know he's eating
[ __ ] for lack of a better term you know
what i mean like he's just he's just
trying to figure
this out and the thing is is that a
hundred thousand dollars is the hardest
amount of money to make for a variety of
reasons and that's not me
i'm not the first person to say that
charlie munger said uh who's warren
buffett's uh business partner said the
first hundred grand is a [ __ ]
he even says that uh it's a quote you
can look it up um but anyways
and and there's there's a bunch of
reasons why and so i wanted to kind of
walk through it
uh the first is the the biggest one
which is that when you're when you set
the goal at a hundred thousand dollars
you only think of hundred thousand
dollar opportunities
right and what i mean by that is you're
not like if i were to say hey you need
to make 10 million dollars
you can't 100 grand your way times 100
to get there
right you have to think of a different
way of operating of doing business in
order to make 10 million dollars right
because at that point you know you can't
sell your time like it's not going to
work
right you have to do something else and
so inherently when someone puts the
constraint of i want to make a hundred
thousand dollars on themselves
then they automatically only construct
confine themselves to vehicles where
they have to sell time for money
right which are inherently constraining
which is why it's a [ __ ] right it's
hard
because you literally have to sell your
time in order to do it that being said
most people who've made millions started
with something that got them a hundred
grand and i will tell you personally
the first hundred thousand dollars that
i put in my bank account was by far the
most meaningful that
of all the money that i've made in my
life um i remember when i looked at
layla and i had a hundred thousand
dollars in my bank account after
everything
um i remember looking at her and saying
it's gonna be okay
we've got three and a half years of
money now that if we mess up for three
and a half years
we'll still we'll still be all right and
i remember feeling
that that sense of relief and the reason
that i think it was so impactful is that
difference between zero or let's say the
difference between
a thousand dollars you're making a
hundred thousand dollars is a hundred x
increase
for me to have that same hundred x
increase i'd have to go from a hundred
thousand ten million in my bank account
to have the same
proportional increase in terms of
security
and i'll tell you even after i 10
million my bank account i was like
it still didn't feel as good as the
first hundred grand all right and so it
doesn't matter where you're at like i'll
tell you
if it's hard right now it's normal it's
supposed to be hard but it will get
better
because you're gonna start thinking
differently all right now back to the
original
topic of why 100 000 the hardest money
to make first is you think of time
vehicles time for money vehicles the
second is that you have no leverage
all right so what i mean by that is that
inherently all businesses arbitrage
right you're buying and selling
things at less and you're making the
difference right if you're in a service
business i'm buying people's labor and
i'm selling it
at a higher price to the marketplace
because i see the discrepancy between
that and i can add value to a person by
training them in certain ways or putting
them inside of a system
and then the sum of the individuals or
sorry the sum of the holes greater than
parts right
that's essentially what it is but when
you don't have money
you have no leverage on anything and so
you have to do
everything yourself and so again it
takes tons of time to get small amounts
of
output and so because of that you're
really inefficient
right because you have to and you also
have to wear all of the hats you have to
learn
every aspect of the business in order to
really turn the first dollar
and that takes time and it takes effort
uh a lot more effort than you think it
will
right and then once you finally figure
out how to make the first dollar you
have to keep repeating that action over
and over and over and over again until
you have
you know a hundred thousand dollars in
your bank account but once you have that
you can start paying people to do things
you can start paying for
you know advertising and you're not
worried about paying your rent
or and what happens is you now start
having the big l word right which is
leverage you can
you can you can move the world a lot
faster because you can have 10 people
doing outbound for you you can pay a
team to make
advertising for you you can have a video
set up or whatever that's going to get
you a higher roi or make your stuff look
better and you get more
you know you get more engagement or
whatever right but the thing is is that
that first hundred grand
is so hard because the vehicles that
exist for it require all your effort if
you're doing
sales right you're working all the time
if you're doing a job you're working all
the time if you're
you know if you wanted to drive uber to
make 100 grand you probably work 12
hours a day
and it would require other time but the
thing is is that once you do that though
you can you can then start piecemealing
out pieces of your day
and you do that in reverse order of the
value
that you can buy that same skill in the
marketplace so let me let me dive into
that for a second
so let's say that in your business you
might be doing
15 different things but you might find
out that the administrative work of
scheduling
and answering the phone might be the
least valuable it may be it may not be
whatever but let's just say it is
and let's say that the marketplace you
can buy that skill for ten dollars an
hour
and so what that means is you can get
let's say four hours of your day back
for ten dollars an hour and so now you
have four more hours
and if you can make more money in those
four hours and this is a key point
i see this one as a mistake too is uh
people will outsource certain work that
they're doing but they will not replace
the time with higher value skill
so then they basically just pay people
and then stop working you make the same
amount of money which
can be cool but if you want to grow then
you're going to need to continue to work
and just do higher and higher and higher
value higher leveraged time
in the time that you buy back right but
fundamentally
when you think about your business as
what would it take for me to make a
million dollars would it take for me to
make 10 million dollars
you think of different vehicles in order
to get there and if you don't know of
the vehicles i would highly highly
encourage you
to look at the vehicles that already
exist so like one of the things that's
here's an interesting nugget for you
there's no reason for anyone in the
united states to make less than 25
an hour why because in one day you can
go through a certification and become a
phlebotomist and make 25
an hour so who wouldn't take a one-day
education
to triple their income from minimum wage
who wouldn't do that
the reason people don't do it is because
they don't know people are ignorant
right and so if you're watching this and
you didn't know that that even existed
there are so many other opportunities
that are like that
that you can immediately get more
leverage on the time just as you're
starting so if you're if you're working
a job and you're not making that
well then go find go find small
opportunities go find little mini
certifications that you can get that
qualify you
uh for now that's only get a
certification if it's required if it's
just like oh this is a certain don't
worry about it but like
if if you can find these little
opportunities you know like i'll tell
you for me my plan b
of like if my business was going to fail
i knew that what i was going to do
was i was going to drive uber and i was
going to strip at night that was going
to be my 100 my
my gig because i knew that if i drove
uber 12 hours a day and i stripped for
four hours
uh every night i would be able to make
about 200 grand and i knew that even
though i started at zero i could do that
again
and try and try and get another do-over
right and the thing is is that as your
skill set
increases right the base level of your
building as i like to consider like this
is your building of skills
the base level your basement continues
to rise right
and so the level that you can fall down
to continues to go
be higher and higher right and so once i
learned how to sell i knew that i would
never
really make less than 250 000 a year
because i knew i could always go to a
car dealership
and sell cars no matter what i could go
sell cars make 200 300 400 000 a year
i knew that because i had that skill and
that means that from this point going
forward with my life i'll never make
less than that
right but then i learned how to market
and then as soon as i learned how to
market i knew that that was going to be
my because now i could take my sales
skill and pair it with marketing and
then i could generate demand
at will right and then that means that
my new level might be three million
dollars a year that i'll never make less
than because i have the skills
that even if i have to start over i can
end there and the thing is is that
if you think about your your journey as
an entrepreneur in terms of
as a skill set stacking all you're doing
is acquiring skills and putting in your
back
pocket put it in your tool kit right
then you inherently become more valuable
and you stop
seeing your failures as failures but
rather
lessons on the way to where you're
trying to go because you inherently
become more valuable because
your work works on you more than you
work on it all right i'll say that again
your work works on you more than you
work on it and so even if you didn't
make a hundred grand the first year
that's okay because you developed
the foundational skill sets that maybe
got you above 50 000 a year
right but as long as you were continuing
to acquire skills
that baseline will will go up and the
speed with which you move
up will be how much volume you do so
volume
of work for a specific skill with
deliberate effort
will improve your skill set now you can
do it faster or slower depending on how
quickly you learn the skill
but you still have to learn it and
there's usually a certain amount of
volume that has to happen which means
that there's some amount of time
but then how do some people acquire
skills faster than others some people
are more deliberate with their practice
some people get mentors and experts that
feed into them
every valuable skill that i've acquired
in my life i've paid someone to acquire
so i could get it faster
all right and so if you're like well i
don't have money then do the high value
do the do the leverage do the shitty
work now do the first 100 000
that's a [ __ ] do that work now you have
to trade some of your
your life for money and that's okay
which is why i have a saying which is
you can uh you can't be busy and broke
right you can't be both if you're busy
you should be making money
right and if you're broke you're not
busy which means you've got time so you
can always trade
back and forth time for money right if
you have more money
then uh and but you're busy all the time
then you can trade some of that money
back to buy some time back right but you
can't be busy and broke
all right so think about that and if you
feel like you are busy and broke i
guarantee you're wasting all your time
so anyways uh to ring this full circle
a hundred thousand dollars is by far one
of the hardest amounts of money to make
because we think about
it only in time vehicles and for many of
us it's the first thing you have to do
so just bite the bullet go do it and
then after that
you can start leveling up your skill set
you can pay for skills
you can pay for um for things to happen
faster for you can pay for other people
to do some of the lower value work
that you're doing because they're
earlier on in their journey so you can
buy their time that's less valuable than
yours
and you continue to work up and build
the foundation of that building that
eventually becomes a skyscraper
of your skills and then you'll have the
perspective to identify
the 10 million the 100 million the
billion dollar opportunities
and go all in on them because at this
point you'll have the skill set to make
it happen
so anyways hope that was valuable for
you hope you're having an amazing day
uh and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you